Hello everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Conner's again. We're going to go over
the presentation that I did the other day and it didn't have any sound. So
this is working now. I can see that. So to better understand food antigens
is
imported
Whether you're dealing with cancer, lime or just tummy aches or any any condition whatsoever because
if you've watched any of my other presentations, all disease can begin with the gut
and at least the gut has a component of every disorder. That's my opinion. Literally every disorder
and after this, I think you'll better understand why I say that. So food antigens. First of all,
what is an antigen? An antigen is just the name that we give
anything that stimulates an immune response. So typically a virus that got into your bloodstream
would be an antigen because it would stimulate an immune response.
In general, antigens are supposed to be
if everything was perfect, the only antigens would be biotoxins, meaning viruses, bacteria,
molds, fungus that get into the body to stimulate an immune response. Because remember,
what does the immune system do? It does one thing. It kills things. And your immune system
doesn't detoxify. Your immune system is supposed to kill enemies. So in cancer patient,
a rogue, rapidly replicating cell, aka cancer, should be an antigen because it's not actually
like a normal cell. It should be recognized as an enemy. In the immune system should kill it.
And that happens in all of us, probably on a daily basis. Something happens within a cell. It starts
replicating and the immune system goes, what the heck is that? Let's kill it and it destroys it.
Because it recognizes it as an antigen. So anything that the immune system recognizes as an
enemy is an antigen. So why would food be an antigen? That's a problem, right? So food is
something we're supposed to eat, digest, break down, and to absorb the nutrients. And for that
to energize us and become a part of us and fuel our everyday function. Food shouldn't be an antigen.
It should never be an antigen. We're going to explain why and the problem in that for cancer
patients and any other patient in this presentation. So the common food antigens, the most common is
is gluten and followed by dairy. And then eggs and other things can be food antigens. Why they become
antigens is the question that we'll talk about. There are certain tests that you can do to find out
these antigens. There's numerous tests on the market. I only like the Syrex test because it tests for
peptides of these things and I'll explain why. So when we look at gluten, let's use gluten as an
example, all right? So if we eat gluten, gluten is the protein that is in wheat. And it's actually
the protein is called gliaden. So the gliaden in wheat should break down into amino acids and then
should go across the gut wall and we should absorb those amino acids. So just a little bit of
physiology 101. When you eat something, it's broken down. So in your stomach, you used a
Crete HCl and the hydrochloric acid in the stomach breaks down carbohydrates mainly which would be gluten.
And it or at least the carbohydrate portion of the wheat and then it's that bolus of food gets
created into the smaller test of that first part of the smaller test of that duodenum is where your
where your pancreas makes enzymes to be secreted into that into the duodenum and your liver makes
bile that's held in the gallbladder that's then secreted into the duodenum to break down the bile
breaks down fat. The HCl from the stomach is the biggest thing that breaks down the carbohydrates
and then the enzymes from the pancreas break down protein mainly. There's a mixture of that but
but that's the main just of it. So first of all you have to break down food to its smallest components
so you could absorb it across the membrane of the intestinal wall. So the intestinal wall is made up
of cells that are tightly packed together and they have very small little crevices in between them
that are actually called tight junctions. So these tight junctions allow only very small particles
to go through and then some particles go through receptors on the epithelial cells themselves
that lie in the intestinal wall and that's how it gets into the bloodstream and it circulates in
the blood and our body uses those. So when we're talking about breaking down a protein
what is a protein? So first let's take a look at that. Glyadin protein. Think of a protein as a
long beaded chain of a pearl necklace. That's the best way I can describe it. Each one of those
pearls is an amino acid and each one of those amino acids are different amino acids and the sequence
and how those amino acids are arranged is what makes up a different protein. So gluten,
glyadin protein is different than casing dairy protein because of the sequence on the number
of amino acids in that beaded pearl necklace. But that beaded pearl necklace is what you ate.
So you chewed it up and you broke maybe even some of that pearl necklace into pieces and then you
swallow it at an HCl doesn't break it down too much. So it goes into the small attested and it's
and it's that first part of the small attested that enzymes are secreted and these enzymes think of
them as scissors. They're cutting up that beaded necklace and the whole purpose of it is by the time
it gets farther down into the small attested. Remember you got 20 feet of small attested, 10 feet of large
attested at least 30 feet of gut that these enzymes are working on. Snippin it, snippin it,
snippin it, snippin it, snippin it, snippin it into little pieces so that it gets down to one little
bead or two little beads at the maximum for it to go through and when it breaks it down into one or two
little beads it's no longer gluten anymore. It's no longer casing, it's no longer that protein anymore.
It's simply it'll be no acid and if there's just one bead it is solely it'll be no acid.
If there's two beads then let's call it a die peptide. If there's more than one bead, more than two
beads let's say there's ten beads that's called a peptide so it might be a peptide shade of
ten that was from Gliann and it could be a peptide shade of 27 or peptide shade of 35.
And it's still going to be recognized as Gliann depending on how many amino acids they're still in
that shade. But those should never get across the gut wall because those tight junctions of cells
are very closely held together because they're very healthy and these peptides of ten or 20 or 30
don't get across so they stay in the lumen of the intestine until the little scissors enzymes
snip them into little pieces until they're down to one or two pieces and then they can sneak
between those cells and get into the bloodstream and in the bloodstream they break down into
amino acids by themselves and then our body utilizes those amino acids to build muscle to go
and build cell membranes and receptor sites and do all sorts of wonderful things. That's how our
body works. But the problem comes in is if our cells of our intestine got damaged maybe because
we had to take it into myotic or maybe because we consumed some GMO foods or maybe because we had
flavorings and additives and colorings we eat to much sugar and junk food and preservatives and
chemicals and all this stuff that we eat on a daily basis that damages that cell wall. So that
cell wall is now not a tight junction of cells there's missing cells and damaged cells and now that
tight junction is separated. It's called intestinal permeability or the comedy is leaky gut.
So now there's gaps between the cells and damaged cells and broken down cells
so these larger peptides that were never supposed to get into the bloodstream in the first place
are now sneaking through these gaps that are damaged in sections of 10 or 20 or 30. They get
into the bloodstream and if they do so they're not just amino acids anymore they're these long chain
peptides and our immune system goes what the heck is that oh my gosh what does the immune system do
does it escort things out of the body hey you're not supposed to be here you come with me let's get
you out of the body no our immune system doesn't do that our immune system does one thing and it does
it well it kills things so the immune system tries to kill it it says what are you doing here what is
this thing this giant snake in the bloodstream let's kill it so it fires this response this
TH1 this immune system responds the marine core of the immune system to go and kill this
food antigen it's a peptide of gliadin well of course it's not living I can't die it's not gonna die
so your damaged gut continues to allow these sections of this pearl necklace across and our immune
system is going bulkers try to kill this and that itself is a bad thing because when we're trying
to fight cancer try to kill kids ourselves though our immune system is reacted to all this other
garbage that it never supposed to react to these cells that go rogue and start replicating in my liver
can now elude the immune response because my immune response is too busy trying to clean up all these
food antigens because they're getting across a damaged gut membrane and of course it gets worse
because these food antigens aren't living organisms so they don't die so your marine core side of
the immune system continues to try to kill them and then pretty soon the marine core are pulled off
and the FBI side of the immune system which is the TH2 side or the B cell side goes in there it makes
antibodies against them so now you have antibodies against gliadin peptides circulated your blood
circulated in the lumen of the intestine and every time you eat this you fire this huge immune
response again and you have this chronic ramped up inflammation to these food antigens where
that's not good at all you can't fight cancer your your army of your immune system is so fighting so
as fighting so many battles at so many different fields that it's very difficult to win the battle
of this cancer that's growing inside your body that's why I like to do this cyrax lab test I said
there's multiple different labs and the reason why I like cyrax is because they test for the different
antibodies of the different peptides not just gluten as a antibody people come in and they go well
no I read a gluten test I my doctor did a blood test on gluten well let me see it oh it's a
gliadin antibody test huh that means you had to have such a damage got that the entire pearl necklace
had to get through the gap for your immune system to make antibodies to the entire gliadin
most of the time you're not that bad you got a damage got wall so these peptides this 10 20 17 32
peptides of gliadin have gotten through in your bodies making antibodies to them well that won't
show what a gliadin antibody test that's the whole protein it's only going to show it a peptide
antibody test that's why cyrax is so far superior so ready this test on it on people is very good it's
not just testing for peptides of glutes testing for about 2 300 different foods that you could have
this going on I just gave you the example of gluten here so we have to look at that these peptides
cross the gut border these sections these pieces of the pearl necklace cross the gut border
the immune system sees them as an enemy therefore there are what right they're an antigen
so our immune system fires this th water response that's the marine core
trying to kill it causing this wrapped up systemic inflammation can't kill it because not living
so you'll fire a th 2 response and what is the th 2 or b cell response do it makes antibodies
so you've created antibodies against a food and now every time you eat that food you're going to
fire an immune response and every time you have this chronic wrapped up immune response the other
negative side of it is you're now damaging the gut even more so you got all these fires going
on in your body and you might not even have any got symptoms zero none but you got all these little
fires going out of the body how could you kill cancer how could you kill lime how could you do it
how could you fight any chronic disease you just can't not good so we have to see how you know your
body is responsive responded to these things clean these out get rid of these foods out of our
diet for a period time allow these antibodies to calm down do things to heal the gut border
so that dead our immune system can focus on what we want it to focus on okay the same things true
with dairy same things true with soy cord etc all these different tests so we have to test for this
here's an example of a section of just the first page this is a ray 4 from Syrex I do a ray 10
on most people which test for I don't know two three hundred different foods so it tells us do
the do we have antibodies that's the thing in the yellow in the red oh boy we do and this this
person has KC antibodies and the way protein antibodies and oat antibodies and coffee antibodies
that would stick and deaf and egg and cord deaf is in a lot of gluten free things so they really need
to clean those out of the body because every time out of their diet because every time they eat
something that's going to fire an immune response and they're quite to have damaged gut borders
and not do well so that's why you look at food antigens that's why you clean out the diet
um this may be a good test to run on everybody think is it's not super cheap but it can be very
valuable to solve problems that you've been chasing for a very very long time so hope this helps
hope you understand that better why we look for food antigens why it's important for you to heal
from all sorts of things even when oh my goodness I got breast cancer why would I look at that I don't
have stomach problems well now I hope you better understand that all right thank you very much
and if you want to contact us the websites on the slides thanks bye bye